we've been hearing about apple's plans
to launch a completely portless iphone
for a couple of years now but i haven't
really seen anyone go really deep into
explaining all of the reasons why apple
might want to do this and how they'll
actually be able to pull it off for a
wide range of people without causing a
bunch of issues so in this video i'm not
only going to answer those questions but
i'm going to go in depth with technical
explanations on how the different
possible solutions will actually
transfer data without requiring a port
so with that said the first thing we've
got to do is quickly run through all the
portless iphone rumors we've had over
the years before i blow your mind with
some apple patent filings way back in
december of 2019 we got our first rumors
of a portless iphone from ming chi quo
reporting that we should expect at least
one iphone model in 2021 to have no port
at all which of course didn't happen and
then last year quo cooled off on those
rumors saying that if the iphone
abandons lightning in the future it may
directly adopt the portless design with
mag safe support instead of a usb c port
however he also said that right now the
mac safe ecosystem is not mature enough
so the iphone will continue to use the
lightning port for the foreseeable
future now i don't know if i agree about
that because we did get some rumors of
apple switching to usb-c with their
iphone 14 pro lineup but i do agree that
apple will be using the mag safe puck to
make the iphone go portless and in just
a minute i'll explain how the technology
required for transferring data from a
portless iphone to a computer is gonna
work but first we gotta go through the
reasons for why apple would want a
portless iphone in the first place
according to mark german who spoke to
mkbhd on his podcast back in december of
2020 one benefit to going portless is
better water resistance which makes
sense because the lightning port has a
bunch of metal contacts inside of it as
well as potential cracks that can allow
water to seep through if there's enough
water pressure not to mention salt water
which is the worst danger for the iphone
so by removing the port the iphone
should handle water pressure much better
and it may even allow apple to make the
iphone salt water resistant just like
the apple watch already is especially
since we already know that apple is
planning on removing the physical sim
card tray according to dylan dkt on
twitter now as for some other reasons
mark said that removing the port would
give apple more internal iphone space to
work with which could lead to an even
bigger battery which is always nice but
other than that it would hands down
encourage more people to buy airpods
since they would no longer have the
option of using the lightning port for
wired headphones and then finally
removing the port would greatly speed up
the growth of the magsafe ecosystem
since everyone will be forced to use it
as the only means of charging
and trust me once you try maxsafe you'll
want to buy more mac safe accessories
like my all-time favorite magsafe car
vent charger that i love so with all
that said going portless is a
win-win-win situation for apple on every
single front but now it's time to get
into the topic of how apple will pull
off data transfer from the portless
iphone to the mac safe puck and then
down through the usbc cable into a mac
or a pc and it all starts with a single
patent that apple filed for back in
2017
showing off a wireless charging system
that uses magnets to align a puck that
will wirelessly charge another device
using inductive charging coils and if
that sounds familiar it is because it's
actually the magsafe puck that we
already have so believe it or not apple
filed for this patent back in 2017
and the mind-blowing thing about it is
that they originally planned for it to
handle data transfers as well in this
patent image apple shows an external
charging and data puck magnetically
attaching to the back of an iphone which
proves that it's mac safe but then there
are two optical data transfer modules
one built into the center of the puck
and one built into the iphone so that
data will flow into the puck and down
the cable to a computer like it
literally says in this drawing so it's
crazy to think that the magsafe puck was
originally designed with data transfer
in mind and if we take a look at a
teardown of the magsafe puck there is
clearly enough room to put in this
so-called optical data transfer module
but apple obviously held off on this
part because it won't be needed until
apple reveals the portless iphone but if
you're wondering how apple plans to
transfer data using the 2nd gen mac safe
puck apple explains it very clearly in
their patent filing they'll be
transferring data by shining light
through a puck optical window emitted at
various frequencies to send and or
receive data to a device such as an
iphone and if you're wondering what a
puck optical window is it's a special
material on the inside of the puck that
a user cannot see through at all
but optical signals could still transmit
through and more specifically they said
that this material could be fully
transparent to infrared or ultraviolet
light while being reflective to regular
visual light and what exactly is that
optical window well if you take a look
at the max save puck that thin off-white
material is actually what apple was
talking about all along in the patent
you can't see through it but data can
travel through it in the form of
infrared or ultraviolet light so with
all that said the way that the portless
iphone could work with data transfer is
that it's going to come with an optical
data transfer module inside of it which
will then shine uv or ir light in the
form of an optical data signal into a
matching module within a second gen
magsafe puck which would then send the
data to the computer through the usbc
cable at blazing fast speeds and i know
it's going to be blazing fast for sure
because back in 2017 researchers at
eindhoven university of technology
achieved a transfer speed of
42.8 gigabits per second using infrared
light to transmit data yes that's faster
than the 40 gigabit per second
thunderbolt 4 standard that we have
today on apple's max and the m1 ipad pro
which is essentially 80 times faster
than the transfer speed of the current
lightning port on the iphone 13 pro max
this would essentially mean full iphone
to mac backups within a couple of
minutes or transferring around 150
gigabytes of pro res video files in
under a minute yes under a minute but
with all that said i know a lot of you
out there are probably skeptical about
this technology actually working
properly for various different reasons
so now let me go through some of those
common concerns first of all one
potential problem is that the iphone
comes with a painted back underneath the
glass which could mess with the optical
data connection however infrared light
actually passes through paint and that's
why infrared is often used to quote see
through paint layers that are
impenetrable to the human eye so i ended
up looking online for some real world
examples and i found a forum post on
avforums.com
where a user buried his sky magic eye ir
or infrared receiver into the surface of
the wall in his kitchen and he wanted to
paint it so that it didn't stand out so
after two layers of paint over the ir
receiver he discovered that it still
worked perfectly fine to transmit data
to his tv system and that was way back
in 2006 so the paint on the back of the
iphone should not cause any problems for
infrared light data transfer but as for
some of the other problems you
unfortunately wouldn't be able to use an
iphone case while transferring data with
the mac save puck so you'd have to take
it off every single time you want to use
it to transfer data now this is probably
not that big of a deal because airdrop
is by far the most common method to
transfer files and photos but if you're
trying to transfer very large files to a
mac or pc using the cable method you're
gonna have to take the case off to use
this system and in my honest opinion i
feel like this could be a realistic
option for transferring data through a
cable on apple's future portless iphone
especially since apple also created a
system for the optical data transfer
modules within the iphone and mac safe
puck to automatically align with each
other just in case it's not perfectly
aligned and if you think all of this is
just way too crazy there are actually a
couple more options that apple could use
instead if it turns out that this tech
doesn't work as well as apple originally
thought it would like for example they
could pack in a little u1 ultra wideband
chip inside of the max 8 puck and then
have the data converted into a signal
that could pass through the other usbc
end and this would be fairly easy since
the iphone has already packed a u1 chip
ever since the iphone 11. or another
option would be to use the brand new
short range 60.5 gigahertz wireless data
transfer feature that apple secretly
built into the apple watch series 7. so
they would just have to build that tech
into both the portless iphone and the
max a puck to make it work and according
to a mac rumors commenter this
technology would support between 10 and
40 gigabits per second speeds over the
60 gigahertz frequency so it could
easily replace wired connections if it
ends up being reliable enough and the
benefit to using this over the whole
infrared idea is that you won't have to
take your case off at all so that could
actually be a more reasonable choice for
apple since it's more convenient for
users but in either case we know that
apple has some very promising technology
that is able to finally give the iphone
insanely fast 40 gigabits per second
transfer speeds through the mac safe
puck and that right there is what will
make users actually want to upgrade to a
portless iphone i mean i can easily see
apple walk out on stage and announce
this new mac save puck charger that
supports 40 gigabit per second
thunderbolt transfer speeds from a
portless iphone to a mac or ipad pro and
basically everybody who shoots prores
video will instantly want to upgrade and
then i can see apple announced that
because of it going portless this is the
first phone in the world that is
saltwater resistant and it comes with an
even bigger battery and that right there
is how i see apple introducing the
portless iphone and if you totally
disagree with me then go ahead and
comment your thoughts down below but if
you enjoyed this video click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]